il est l'un des mangaka les plus connus
en France et en Europe avec une
trentaine d'albums Giro tanigucci 20 ans
déjà que son œuvre est traduite en
français depuis l'homme qui marche sorti
en
1999 en 40 ans de carrière l'artiste a
su conquérir un public
intergénérationnel grâce à la diversité
des thèmes traités il a commencé comme
plein d'auteurs japonais en faisant son
apprentissage auprès de maîtres et en et
en apprenant à décliner des genres assez
traditionnellement identifiés comme le
interne comme le Polard comme le récit
d'aventure et puis petit à petit il est
allé vers des sujets de plus en plus
introspectifs de plus en plus
contemplatif de plus en plus personnel
et qu'il est un peu le seul au Japon
aujourd'hui à aborder de cette manière
une contemplation orientée vers des
thèmes tels que les racines l'origine la
famille ou encore la nature la richesse
de son œuvre lui a valu différents prix
tels que le prix alphar du meilleur
cénario 2003 et le prix du dessin 2005
au festival d'angoulem une influence
occidentale dans son dessin illustré
notamment au cours de sa carrière par sa
collaboration avec
Moebius ce qui est caractéristique dans
le travail de Tan guucci c'est que cet
homme très tôt et c'est rare chez les
japonais s'est intéressé à la bande
dessinée occidentale il a fait la
démarche d'aller voir ce que c'était et
ça l'a tout de suite touché ça l'a
inspiré et son travail est le produit de
sain c'estàdire à la fois le le produit
de quelqu'un qui est un qui est un
Japonais hein donc qui a un style
vraiment empreint de de ce qu'il y a de
de
chez tous ces auteurs japonais mais
également avec une influence occidentale
au cours de l'exposition un documentaire
lui est consacré il accompagne le retour
de Jiro Taniguchi dans sa ville
japonaise d'origine
Totori